[Music]
perfect segue hello I'm Karen Gordon
from Le talk radio's phone courage we're
here with the lovely Christina Rose who
is in death of the dead and how do you
write a Joe Sherman song now in another
one of Gary Kings movies New York lately
he has a character named Veronica
darling and she's an actress and she
struggles with her own inner demons and
rejection as an actor how do you deal
with that you go out on it casting of
some sort you don't get it or there's
that in-between period how do you deal
with that unknown and the possible
rejection that you might face I think
that it's a growth that as an actress
like in the beginning it's really hard
because you're putting yourself out
there you're not used to it and you were
just putting so much into it that you
want every role that you go out for and
you understand as as you go on in the
business that you can't get every role
that sometimes they just want to look a
blonde instead of the brunette so you
start to understand that you're just
gonna go out there and give a hundred
and ten percent and give your best and I
know at this point in my career that
it's okay if I don't get something
because I book other things and then and
I just want to do good work so I think
it's just the growth in the career as
you get older and as you do more work
you understand that there's so many
actors and actresses out there and you
can't get everything so you just be
thrilled with what you get and work
really hard at those roles so you kind
of learn that you don't take it personal
it could be that you're too tall or
whatever it is and just to not criticize
it exactly yeah I mean and it's not it's
still not easy I mean because as an
actress you're putting yourself out
there this is me I'm the package that
I'm selling
you know you do take it a little
personally but you have to if you're
serious about the career you have to
just move past it otherwise you're just
gonna shut yourself in a room and never
go back out the door and for every like
you know maybe on your roles you
audition for you may not get but one or
two but those two roles are going to
like help make your career so you know
you just you know that the more you go
out there the more opportunities you
have to book something if you never go
out there you're not gonna book anything
so yeah I mean as artists were we're
just sensitive kind of emotional
creatures and I think things probably
affect us more I know they do for me was
there ever a time that you kind of did
doubt for yourself how did you handle
that oh yeah I mean I go like this I
mean I think that you know you you do
have to learn and it's something that we
do learn as actresses and actors that
there is that inner demon sure and that
you you know they're gonna say things to
you and you learn from certain things
that that inner demon does to you but
then you you know to just put it in the
back of your head and and move forward
because we're all gonna have that that
judge that you're talking about and I
think that our support systems are so
important because I have people that
tell me that they believe in me all the
time in and these people these directors
these producers that do good work
believe in me so I know that I have it
and even if you get rejected like like
we said you know you have to just move
past that and be confident I think it's
very important to be confident as an
actress and know and trust your skills
because that way you can go out there
and put out so much and not judge
yourself and hold back because if you
don't make choices and you're too scared
to make choices then you can't make
those beautiful choices that we see on
film and TV
[Music]